calling in is uh my friend longtime
friend from the worldwide leader in
sports and with a couple of stories
popping on frauding and then over the
weekend involving collegiate athletics
the state of Florida Governor Ron de
santis announcing that he has signed
into law that players at the collegiate
level will be able to start making money
off of their name likeness and image
starting in 2021
which beats California to the punch and
then the Ohio State University making
its players and parents of players sign
a Buckeye pledge is what it's being
called by Gene Smith the athletic
director in which it states the signee
understands that they could get kovat if
they get back on the field and it sure
sounds like a waiver so we wanted Jay
Bilas and Jay Bilas Esquire to call all
and at the same time and they and
apparently he has how are you Jay I'm
doing very well rich how are you better
for talking with you let's start first I
guess with that Ohio State Buckeye
pledge that we heard about so much over
the weekend Jay what do you make of this
news is it something that you think is
going to be regular normal for all
schools to do and and and and is it fair
yeah first yeah you're gonna see a lot
of this and it doesn't sound like a
waiver it is one it's a waiver of
liability and and you know you're gonna
see more of this I believe it's there's
an issue called assumption of risk and
and I think the n-c-double-a and the
institution's the member institutions
are looking at sort of the optics of you
know how can you ask an amateur player
to assume the risk of playing in a
multi-billion dollar business you know
if you're a car racer you know racing
for money and in NASCAR Formula One
you're assuming the risk of injury but
you're doing so for a fair amount of
money and they're certainly not doing
that here but you know there's a there's
a odd feel to it to me first of all
calling it a pledge is is a bit you know
but can be seen as a bit misleading
and then the fact that
they have to sign it in order to play
you know it's not a car rental contract
I mean it's a waiver and so it's
interesting I don't know exactly what to
make of it but I think you're going to
see everybody you know everybody using
something similar
one thing about a waiver though is is no
matter what a player is made to or asked
to sign you can't waive negligence so if
just taking Ohio State as an example at
bio state acts in the negligent fashion
and and players are harmed as a result
of that that that's not that can't be
waived so we'll see what happens I mean
I look we all want to see all these all
these sports play but there are issues
that we've not had to confront before
and we can already see that even
University of Houston is you saw
suspended you know their their athletics
right now after so many so many players
tested positive when they when they
first came back so we're we haven't
figured this one out yet it's gonna it's
going to be awhile before we do I do
want to just give gene Smith's
statement and quote a full complete
airing with you Jay saying that the
waiver is intended more for educational
purposes than it is for liability quote
that's why we call it a pledge we don't
look at that as a legal document
it's a Buckeye pledge allow us to help
you so that if we face a situation our
trainers our strength coaches our or
coaches or any athletic administrator
sees a student athlete not wearing a
mask or not social distancing we can say
hey you made a commitment you signed a
pledge your parents on to pledge your
parents are a part of this end quote
yeah and they're asking their parents to
sign it to show not that you know that
they've got unity but so that their
parents can't claim they didn't know and
you know this isn't something where look
I'm not saying that this is sinister
it's not but but the idea that they're
that it's not you know some sort of
legal document of course it is otherwise
they just say everybody raise your right
hand
or put your hand over your heart and
let's all pledge to do this together
they're making them sign it date it and
all that stuff
so it's as legal as it gets there may be
some other things in there as to making
people aware but it's just like we said
before with a lone document you have to
sign all these different things I want
to get alone
and some of them are to make sure that
you're aware of certain things and you
have to sign it because because there
are legal ramifications to it so it's
it's the same thing here everybody's
trying to protect themselves as best
they can
it doesn't mean that Ohio State is doing
it or anybody else is doing anything
wrong and starting up and and bringing
bringing them people back but I I don't
know if you saw I think it was Friday as
well rich there was an article I believe
in Forbes magazine written by Donna
LoBiondo used to be the atletic director
at the University of Texas and by Andrew
symbolist who's a very well-known
economist basically asking as higher
education lost its mind you know the
idea that that reopening athletics right
now goes against most of what we're
hearing from health care professionals
that you know you're being asked not to
fly unless it's absolutely necessary and
then they're flying you know a fleet
send from all over the country for
quote-unquote voluntary workouts the
workouts aren't voluntary they're
they're restarting and they're mandatory
you don't come back you are sending a
strong signal that you're not all in and
so I don't think I don't think any of
the players really are viewing this is
voluntary that they believe it's
mandatory
I guess Jay that you know I know use the
word sinister and
and that's what I think that this is
being viewed through the lens of well
you know we're seeing what the major
league baseball union is doing we're
seeing what the NBA the NBPA
might be involved in right now and we're
gonna talk about what Kyrie Irving said
over the weekend in a moment with Chris
Haines of Yahoo but there is no union
here right and that's where I think a
lot of people when they hear that this
pledge or waiver and again Gene Smith
said he got this pledge from an idea in
a conference call amongst his colleagues
from the athletic director in Indiana
and we're assuming that there's going to
be many other schools that do this the
question is is what what rights do the
players have I guess if they're not
unionized in this regard yeah very few
it's sort of the idea rich of people
saying well and it's usually said when
when the players asked for economic
rights when they asked for money they
say well this is not a mandatory there's
a voluntary activity it's not mandatory
you don't have to play and nobody's
holding a gun to your head type of thing
I hate it when people say that but it's
tradition nobody's holding a gun do you
had to play and then this is the one
I've always disliked that it's a
privilege not a right to play college
athletics well that's nonsense because
you know is it a is it a right to work
for the to be a coach it's not a right
to be a coach that's a privilege to if
you want to look at it that way
but you do have certain rights and I
happen to think that that playing
college sports is a right it's a right
that's earned through competition and
merit and so you know that to me that
doesn't indicate that a player shouldn't
be paid or all that but to the point of
the players have no say essentially in
starting up again it's not like things
are being negotiated the the athletic
directors will tell you well we've been
in constant communication with players
we are listening to their concerns we
have spoken with the parents we have
wide open communication all that stuff
but the decisions are theirs and
everybody like it's amazing to me and
again I'm not casting aspersions on
anyone but just it's amazing to me how
early on in this discussion you
high-ranking officials won the President
of the n-c-double-a is saying if schools
are not open we will not be playing
college sports that if the campuses
aren't open for students you can't have
you can't have athletes on campus and
quickly really quickly that was shot
down and then you said we're if we're
open for online education we're open for
business and athletes can be on campus
and and boy it's it's totally changed
and look I don't know whether we're
moving too fast
just right or not fast enough I'm not
saying any of that all I know all I
believe is I shouldn't say all I know
all I believe is we have no idea what's
going to happen going forward we might
have beliefs as to what's going to
happen but we don't know and you can
just see what states reopening in phase
one that we're having spikes and in
transmission so you know it would be
foolish to think that we're not going to
have it in football and basketball and
all that so we don't know what's going
to happen and so I'm cutting everybody a
lot of slack in that too but but then
you see things like this and you're gone
you know we're really worried about
liability and bringing them back so
we're having a sign a waiver that that
raises some more questions about about
whether we're doing the right thing I
think do you think it is and last one
for you on this before we hit on the
state of Florida do you think it's
enforceable I mean certainly when an
athletic directors on on on record
saying this is not a legal document in
our minds it's just a plug I think I
think if somebody were to bring suit
saying that the university acted
improperly in bringing people back and
therefore the virus was contracted and
and damages were suffered it would
certainly be an issue I think it would
be an important issue in that sort of
action but then you know obviously you'd
have the issue of causation like you
know you can there's no I think it would
be very difficult to tell did you did
you contract the virus from here you
know at least that that seems like it
would be difficult now now maybe we'll
learn more in contact tracing can can
get right to the bottom of it as far as
as far as proving the matter asserted I
just don't know the answer to that but
but you're certainly it's certainly
putting people at a decision
right now I mean I just can't imagine
being presented with that and doing any
as an athlete and doing anything I
wasn't signing it like what are you
gonna do you're gonna take a stand
individually and say I'm not going I'm
not doing this
I don't know it'd be difficult I can't
imagine I if they say hey we're starting
up again I'd feel obligated as an
athlete to go because you have a lot
riding on it not just your not just your
scholarship and the like but but I think
you'd feel like your career in some ways
could be riding on it just just like if
for us if broadcasting starts back and
they say we want you to go do a game
somewhere right like if you're a
broadcaster and they're saying hey we
want you to go four months into this
bubble in Orlando to the NBA yeah you're
gonna be thinking about what does this
mean for my career if I say no even if
you're worried about the the
implications if you've got health issues
whatever it is you know you're gonna be
worried about your career if you say no
no doubt about that
Jay bill is here on the Richardson show
okay and now Rhonda Sanchez the governor
of Florida signing a bill on Friday that
goes into effect in July of 2021 that
says name likeness and image for any
collegiate athlete in the state of
Florida can can earn them a paycheck
what do you make of this news Jay well
it's just the next step in what seems to
be inevitable but I'm not convinced is
inevitable rich it's sort of the the
n-c-double-a allowing athletes economic
rights and in this the limited economic
right of their name image and likeness
to be able to do endorsements and the
like and accept money for that while
you're in college and if you'll call a
little over a year ago I believe
right around tournament time the NCAA
had come out with with a statement
saying that that they wanted to allow
this and it was in direct response to
the state of California passing its name
image and likeness law I think it's
called the fair pay to play act out in
California that was was put through you
know 72 to nothing by senator nancy
skinner and signed by governor Newsom so
the NCAA comes out and says we want to
allow named image and likeness rights as
long as it fits within the collegiate
model and so so many people took that to
be this tremendous victory that look
look what's happening the answer but
he's finally relenting on this and and I
couldn't stop laughing I said they're
not allowing us they said as long as it
fits within the collegiate model and
that's like I've made jokes about it but
it's true that's kind of like saying we
want to allow the players unlimited
showers as long as nobody gets wet so
that's what they're saying and so they
put together this task force or working
group that's that's shared by Jean Smith
who we were just talking about Ohio
State and Val Ackerman of the Big East
and they've come up with all these
recommendations but it buried in the
recommendations is the idea that will
allow this with guardrails which means
restrictions as long as we get an
antitrust exemption from Congress or
Congress puts these rules into federal
law so that it preempts all these
different states that may have variances
and how they're going about it because
Florida and California not the only ones
and and so I don't think they're gonna
do this in the least bit you know you've
already seen different athletic
directors coming out and making
statements that they want to put a stop
to it they're not you know they think
it's wrong all this stuff and so I'm not
confident that that the NCAA really
means this that they really want to do
it I don't believe they do and I think
they're asking Congress for an antitrust
exemption you know so you're you're
you're a recidivist violator of the
federal antitrust laws is asking for an
antitrust exemption you know that that
is the ultimate you know sort of Fox
asking Congress for exclusive access to
the henhouse
that I can recall I mean it's it's
really it's bizarre and it's in how
grandiose that that view is there's no
way they're gonna get that but they
could get legislation that they say okay
here's here's what you know here's the
national standard and let's preempt all
these other states you know we'll see
what happens so you're saying that when
some somebody Garrety pays some player
of do you notice show up at a car
dealership and the NCAA comes down on
that kid
the school members school this is going
to court it's basically you're saying
until this gets figured out well even
before that I think I think what will
happen is if the n-c-double-a is unable
to get traction in Congress for some
sort of legislation before Florida's law
goes into effect I think you'll see the
n-c-double-a sue the state of Florida in
the state of California under some
theory that they violated the United
States Constitution specifically the
Commerce Clause I don't know whether
that'll work or not but it'll certainly
delay things and the more the NCA plate
delays the more they get the status quo
and they more they more they pocket the
billions of dollars that they're making
but I you know to me to me rich this is
really easy you know the answer
everybody likes to make it complicated
but if you want to do name image and
like this you say you start from all
right the players have full economic
rights now if we think that that full
economic rights there are going to be
issues that are going to negatively
affect the competition and negatively
affect the business then let's talk
about reasonable restrictions to
accomplish you know sort of those goals
of having you know sort of the fair
competition something like that instead
the n-c-double-a starts with the premise
of the athletes get nothing
so let's decide where we want to allow
the crumbs to go from the athletes
because we certainly don't want any of
our money going there you know we don't
want anyone whether it's a corporation
or an individual business that usually
gives their money to us taking any of
that money and giving it to individual
athletes because that would be a
negative drain on us and and that's our
money not theirs and that's the that's
sort of the what I call the false
premise the where that the interpolate
uses in trying to decide this you know
we we have the status quo and and we're
not going to change it unless there's
good reason to and it's not going to
affect us and I don't think that's a
very good way to go about it Jay much
appreciated you take care of yourself
stay tuned
I imagine no doubt about it we'll chat
soon
I pledge to come back whenever you and
I'm going to hold you to that series I
will have I will hold you to that and
and and you second that Chris do you
second that second second it that's it
and if they'll to foe thirds or then
it's now it's binding okay now its wha
now it's law that's it take care of
yourself jack the best Thank You Rhett
you got it
Jabil hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here